one of the things i
notice
sleep effects is uh
my ability to see the beauty in the
world
yeah so
um
what do you think is the connection
between sleep in your emotional life
your ability to love other human beings
and love
life
yeah
i think it's
it's very
powerful and strong so
we've done a lot of work in the field of
sleep and emotion and sleeping moods and
you can separate your emotions into two
main buckets
um you know positive and negative and
what's interesting is that when you
are sleep deprived and the more hours
that you go into being
awake and the fewer hours that you've
had to sleep
your
your negative mood starts to increase
and and we we know which individual
types of
emotions are changing i've got a
wonderful um post-doc in my lab called
etti ben simon who's doing some
incredible work on
trying to understand the emotional
individual emotional tapestry
of
affective
meltdown
when you're not getting sufficient sleep
but let's just keep with two dimensions
positive and negative yes
the negat most people would think well
it's the negative that takes the biggest
hit when i'm sleep deprived it's not
by probably in a log order magnitude
larger
is a hit on your positive emotions
in other words you stop
gaining pleasure from normally
pleasurable things and it's a state that
we call anhedonia
and anhedonia
is the state that we often call
depression so depression
to most people's surprise isn't
necessarily that you're
always feeling negative emotions
it's often more about the fact that you
lose the pleasure in the good things in
life that's what we call anhedonia
that's what we see in sleep
and insufficient sleep and it happens
quite quickly yeah it's kind of
fascinating i um
i think i do it's not depression but
like it's uh
it's a stroll into that direction
which is when i'm sleep deprived i stop
being able to see the meaning in life
the things that gave me meanings starts
to lose meaning like stupid i it makes
me realize how enjoyable everything is
in my life because when i start to lose
it when i'm severely sleep deprived you
start to see how much life sucks when
you lose it but that said when i'm just
cognizant enough that like sleep fixes
all that so i use those states for what
they're worth in fact i personally
like to pay attention to the things that
uh
bother me in during that time
because they also reveal
important information to me
um yeah it's interesting i think it's
usually like a raw shock to yeah i mean
there's so i i find this when i fast
combined with sleep deprivation
i am clear to see with people
clear and identifying the things that
are not going right in my life
or um
people that i'm working with are not
doing as good of a job as they could be
doing
um like
people that are negative
uh in my life i'm more able to identify
them so i don't act on that it's a very
bad time to act on those decisions but
you quite well made recording recording
that information
because i usually when i'm well rested
and happy i see the beauty in everybody
which can get you into trouble
so you have to balance those two things
but yes it's fascinating there's an
irony there too which is the fact that
you know when you're well-rested and
well-slept just as you said you see the
the beauty in life and it sort of
enlivens you and sort of gives you a
quality of of life that's emotionally
very different
yet then
we are
contrasting that against the need for
not getting enough sleep because of the
beautiful things that you want to
accomplish in life
and i don't actually see them as
you know sort of completely
or paradoxical because i still think
that you can strive for all of the
brilliant things that you are striving
for to have the monumental goals the
herculean challenges that you wish to
take on and solve
they can still enthrall you and excite
you and stimulate you
but
because of the insufficient sleep that
they can or that
goal can produce
it will shave off
the beauty of life that you experience
in between and again this is just about
the trade-off
i will say though that and this is not
um
applicable to your circumstance
um
we
do know that insufficient sleep
is very strongly linked to suicide
ideation
suicide attempts and tragically suicide
completion as well
and in fact in 20 years of studying
sleep
we have not been able to discover a
single psychiatric condition in which
sleep is normal
and i think that that is a profound
state i think it tells us so much about
the role of sleep as a potential causal
agent in psychiatric conditions i also
think it's a potential
sign that we should be using sleep as a
tool yeah for the prevention of grave
mental illness yeah it's both a cause
and
and a solution so yeah i i mean me
personally i've gone through a few dark
periods
uh quite recently and it was almost
always sleep is not the cause
but sleep is the catalyst from going to
uh a bad time to a very bad time
yeah and so it's it's
definitely true and it's funny how sleep
can just cure all of that there's
actually a beautiful quote by an
american entrepreneur called e joseph
kosman
who once said that the best bridge
between despair and hope
is a good night's sleep
and i spill
it's quite so much ink and hundreds of
pages inelegantly trying to say the same
thing in my book
and he said it in one line and
it's beautiful
you